You
oh
me
Thanks for watching, and I'll see you in the next video!
Hello? Hello? Hi! Time for a normal YouTube stream! How's the mic? Is it okay? I actually didn't- I didn't test it. Hold on, let me test it. Is it okay? It sounds good. You're not lying!
Okay. Okay. I ordered a new wire, but for now I'll have to use my drawing tablet wire.
I've completely given up on using straws to make my tracking not, you know, make it look like I'm drinking. She doesn't ever believe we're telling the truth, because you guys don't know, like, I don't know how to explain it, like, you guys don't know what I consider, like, messed up mic, I guess? Why is my mouth tracking kinda shit too?
You guys don't know what I consider messed up mic, so like, that's why I don't always trust- oh, and there goes- there goes my entire tracking, hello? That's why I don't always, um, trust you. You know? Sorry.
Am I here? Am I alive? Okay. I don't even know if I would consider myself a perfectionist because, like, I don't know what, um, I don't know what is good. I just know what I'm trying to aim for, you know? Maybe you don't know.
Yeah, too many yes men. Say no. Tell me my mic looks like- tell me my mic sounds like shit. Tell me it sounds like I'm using an Xbox mic. That's what I want you to say. Okay?
Okay. Anyways, hold on.
Alright, so today we're gonna be reviewing shitty iPhone games. It's technically a lie where we're reviewing shitty, um, iPad games. We're gonna be iPad kids today together.
Um, Blue Yeti mic. I'm actually not using a Blue Yeti. I'm using a HyperX Quadcast mic.
Um, I do got games on my phone and I'll show you. I'll show you my games on my phone. It's sorta quiet, to be honest. Oh my god.
Now you're- now you- now the brain worms are starting. It shouldn't be quiet. Hold on. Let's start recording. Testing, testing. One, two, three. AHHHHHHH! Okay.
Now you're gonna listen to that with me.
Honestly, I couldn't tell. I have to use different headphones, I feel like. Whatever. It's fine. It's fine. Tell me it's fine.
Um, did you get mom's iPad? Yeah. I found a bunch of shitty games to play and I downloaded them on mom's iPad.
How old should you be to start being a burner? What's a burner? Quieter than usual, not quiet per se.
Whatever, it's okay. Um, I- I- I- I- For now it's fine. Oh, Reefling Raid! Hi, Reeflings! Welcome! How are you guys doing? Momerate.
You guys were playing- you were playing Overwatch? Pop, pop, pop, get raided, hi! Hello! Welcome! Wow, it's short? Only four hours? That's crazy.
That's crazy. Mom- Mom, are you tired today? Only four hours? Okay. Oh, Overwatch was yesterday? Damn. Okay. I called- I told them that I called that your short would get popular and it did.
You did call that my short would get popular, but I didn't expect it to get popular because, like, I don't know, I made other shorts similar to that and it never got popular. But this time it did! I don't know, six times- six times the charm.
But it didn't really get popular amongst the VTuber watchers as I can tell in chat. First Tuber- First Tuber I'm watching didn't get popular amongst the VTuber watchers, kind of got popular amongst the normies that don't really know what VTubers are and are, like, you know, questioning everything about me and my existence and why I exist.
Yeah, the real voice one. Yeah, you know normies, it's okay as long as they're being respectful, which a lot aren't, but some are. I'll try to educate the respectful ones.
Um, right, hold on. So, okay, this is gonna be a little bit scuffy. I don't think I'll get a virus because, you know, doesn't Apple, like, test their apps? I would hope so.
I would hope Apple test their apps. I don't know, maybe they don't, and maybe I will get a virus, we'll see. But I got them all from the app store, so I'm hoping it'll be okay.
I'm hoping it'll be okay. Now, yeah, this is gonna be a little scuffed because I wanted to mirror my iPad screen, but because I didn't plan ahead, I couldn't use my capture card because I didn't have the right dongle.
I didn't buy the right dongle ahead of time. So, my last, um, my last, I guess, line of, my plan Z is to just call myself on Discord and share my screen that way.
Apple compliance is pretty strict when it comes to stuff that can access camera, payment info, etc. Well, I hope, uh, I put tape on my camera, so hopefully you shouldn't see me, but I don't know what else you might see.
Okay, hold on, let me go to the gaming screen.
Okay, someone keeps asking, how old should you be to start tubing? You can be any age, as long as you're older than 13, because most sites have a limit of 13. But if you're 13, don't watch this stream, go away, child.
Just because we're playing children's games does not mean we want the children here with us. Okay, let me call myself on Discord. One second, um, call.
Wait, I already have a friend request. What?
Call.
Friend request failed. Oh, I'm such a fucking idiot. I put my, I put my iPad on airplane mode, and I was wondering, why isn't the call going through? Why is the call feeling? It's because you have no fucking Wi-Fi, you idiot.
Okay, hold on, let me try something.
Okay.
Sorry, I'm being a noob right now, give me a second.
Make me join call. Oh.
Okay, there we go. I had to mute both of myself.
Share your screen. Oh wait, no, not that screen. The iPad screen.
Share your screen. Start broadcast.
I'm getting there, I'm getting there, give me a second, give me a second.
It's not because I'm lonely, it's because I'm trying to show you my iPad screen.
Okay, let's make that full screen. Okay, so let me show you the games that I have today. Now the quality's ass, um, but you know, it was either this or Zatsu, and this is basically a Zatsu anyway, so this is just like a more fun version of a Zatsu basically.
And there goes my face again. Ah!
Oh.
Huh?
Oh no.
Guys, I'm frozen!
What happened?
Thank you for becoming a member. Give me a second.
I'm almost there, okay? Everything was working when I started stream. There we go, okay.
Okay, let me show you the fucking games that we have today. Sorry, I'm in a really shitty position on my desk, so it's kind of hard for me to, um, to do this.
So, um, let me go full screen. Okay, can I go fuller screen than this?
Probably not.
Oh, maybe I can. Sorry, I'm a little bit of a noob.
Um, there we go, okay. And this is the iPad.
Do you like my 1080p quality here? Hold on.
Let me, um, I have to show you the full screen, don't I? Excuse my 129 discord message.
Okay, there we go.
There we are. Right, so the apps that we have today are pregnancy simulator, baby in yellow, I don't know what that means.
Uh, fart world? Jerry mouse rat? I just looked up like rat simulator.
Um, the next one is called like makeover makeup ASMR. It's like one of those gross, um, like makeover games.
And then we have like a doctor simulator. We have granny evil nun, and we have an AI girlfriend.
So as you can see, we have a lot of great, um, great options today.
John this baby. I don't think that's what it's supposed to be.
I don't know, let's, let's, let's jump right into it.
Um, so this was called pregnant pregnancy simulator.
So we're going to pretend that the condom broke today.
Now this one looks especially bad quality because it is especially bad quality.
Like even on my iPad, it's like really, I mean, they're all shitty quality games. It doesn't matter.
Granny evil is rough. Is it child support? You're going to have to start being child support.
Okay, play. So I guess we have to like unlock, I don't know why the last one says that.
I guess we have to unlock the, the various levels of, of pregnancy life.
And the first one is chapter one, a new journey of life is starting soon where we'll have less sleep,
but more happiness because a little member is joining us soon. You guessed it right. I'm pregnant.
I'm the mother. I'm the mother. What do you mean? And you're the father.
Yeah, we'll probably get a lot of ads. That's okay though. As long as the ads don't fucking dox me.
I'll have, I'll have my mouse ready. Okay.
Um, so I can't look around. I can only just move around, but I can't look where I'm going.
So I guess we're going to the reception desk.
Um, should I, should I show you the audio of the game?
Can you hear any audio?
I don't know if the game has audio to be honest. It's very possible it doesn't. I don't know.
Now, should I let you hear the audio and I'll show you the audio? This looks bad, but better than I expected. It just looks bad.
Madam, how can I help you?
Oh no. I'm having nausea, fatigue, vomiting for the last three days. Oh, I guess my name is Amanda.
Take your slip and go to the radiology table for ultrasound, then visit the gynecologist with your reports.
Okay. Don't call me Amy. I'm Amanda now.
Oh, now I can look around. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Where's my file? Oh, thank you, ma'am.
Oh, oh, did I pass the level already?
Wait, what? Thank you for the 20 gems.
Oh, okay. We're here for our, our, our, uh, oh, can I walk around here?
Wow. I like how this one is cropped badly.
Amanda, you got 13% pregnant from doing that. Wait, what do you mean? 13%? Did you see a percentage around here?
I like how I can like click the button on the right to just watch an ad, I'm guessing.
What is the date, patient form? I didn't fill out my form.
Work injury, work injury. People work injury twice.
Accident other. Did this problem require surgery? No, yes, yes.
They put multiple options twice. Date of surgery, signature date. Okay.
Oh, can I like play with this stuff? I'm guessing no.
I like to do this at doctor's offices. I'm not going to lie.
I haven't been to many doctor's offices, but I like to snoop around while I'm waiting for them because they make you wait like fucking 20 minutes for them.
Sometimes more, you know, so I just snoop around.
Oh, the report system.
Oh, can I, can I steal some coffee, confidential patient information here?
No.
Do they make you play this after getting pregnant?
No. Okay, let's sit down. Hi, I'm pregnant. Here's my ultrasound slip. Give me an ultrasound.
Please lay down straight on the bed, on bed.
You ever take things from the drawers? No, of course not. No, I don't. Do you?
It's not a big chair. It kind of just looks like a... Oh, okay.
She forced me onto the table. Oh my.
Alright, she's... Don't I have to lift my shirt for this kind of stuff?
Is that it? That was fast.
Okay, I look a little bit disgruntled.
You have to wait 20 minutes. I'm Canadian, so it's more like one to two hours.
I mean, I'm Canadian too.
But no, usually when you go, they'll like make you wait in the waiting room and then they'll put you in a room and they'll make you wait again.
But usually I... Oh, now I'm 26% pregnant.
Usually there's always a little bit of a wait. I guess it depends on the...
I just got an ad.
I live with my parents and I got $0 and my dad wants to kick me out, so tell me, what would you do?
Can I... No, I don't want...
Bit life. I've played bit life before, actually.
We're 26% preggers!
And it's all your fault you made me this way.
Okay, I'm done here. I don't want to download bit life.
It won't let me leave the ad.
Hello?
Wait, I can't leave the ad.
I can't leave the ad at all.
Come on! Let me try restarting the game.
But then I'll have to do the whole thing again, won't I?
Do you think it saves progress in this shitty game?
Play.
We have to start all over again.
Man!
They wouldn't let me leave the ad.
Yeah, you're 26% the father.
Oh, did it... Did it save my progress? I think it did.
Okay. Oh, I have a new patient form now.
Alright, no, I just have a green paper now.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're gonna get more pregnant now.
Oh, now we're in the gynecology room.
Ooh, where's all the pictures of pussies?
Excuse me.
There's not really much.
Every picture is like super low res.
Oh, wow.
Natural ways to lower uric acid levels.
Okay, cool.
Oh, he looks concerned.
Just waited until I find the other 74%.
Hi, doctor.
What happened, young lady?
I got pregnant, doctor.
I'm having nausea, fatigue, and vomiting since last three days.
Do you have your ultrasound report?
Yes, here it is.
Okay, let me check your reports first.
Congratulations, you're pregnant.
He does look like he's seen some terrible stuff.
Really? Thank you so much, doctor.
This is your diet plan.
Follow it, and you should come for regular...
Diet? I'm on a diet because I'm pregnant?
I don't want to take your stupid diet.
Yeah, I'm pregnant.
That would be $400.
Yeah, no, they don't immediately do an ultrasound.
They'll probably just tell you to go home and take a pregnancy test at home.
Let's go!
Pregnancy acquired, 38%.
Please don't make me watch another ad.
Okay, I'm home now.
Oh, wow, I have a really nice house.
I guess I can afford to be happy that I'm pregnant.
Go to your bedroom and hang the car keys on the key holder.
Wow, look at my house, dude.
Holy shit.
Wow, I live in a nice neighborhood.
Holy crap.
Can anyone identify where this house is from?
I'm learning so much.
I know, wow.
Is this what it's like to be pregnant?
Oh, shit, I'm on the...
Oops, okay.
Is this what it's like to really be pregnant?
Excuse me.
Why is my TV so small?
Okay, sorry.
Do I have to go to the father of my child and tell him?
Wait, go to the bedroom, hang the car keys on the key holder.
Which one is the key holder?
Oh, look, I got an iPad.
Whoa, what's that?
Wow, I'm a healthy person, huh?
Where's the key holder?
Folic acid.
Where is my key holder?
Do any of you see she looked at it?
Where is the key holder?
Which one is the key holder?
Oh, psh.
There we go.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Okay, now place the bag on the table.
This table?
This table, right?
Or no, probably this table.
I just want to tell my husband that I'm pregnant.
Oh, there it is.
Hello?
Okay.
The game isn't gaming, okay, I'm struggling.
The baby took my eyesight.
That's true.
I don't think that's true, but there's a lot of fucked up shit that happens when you get pregnant.
I'm destined to be the best player of all time.
So if that means I have to start with the worst team in the league, I'm going to do it.
The Memphis Honey Bay, huh?
Alright, let's try out as a shooting guard.
Can I shut it up?
Okay, there we go, sorry.
Okay, please.
BitLife again?
Please let me exit out.
Please let me exit out of the game.
BitLife, you're making me hate you right now.
No, I don't want to download BitLife.
Okay.
Am I in the third stage of pregnancy?
Pick up the phone and call your husband.
I'm pregnant!
She looks so mad.
As with it, as with it, as.
I have been trying to impress the ex, but sometimes it doesn't work.
Hello?
David?
Hi honey, everything alright?
I have news.
I am pregnant, carrying a little life in my womb.
Like, seriously?
You're expecting her first child?
Yes!
She doesn't look happy at all.
Oh my god, I'm so excited.
Honey, I'm coming home.
See you soon.
Am I going to go have sex with David now?
I'm just merging in with the bed.
Enjoying pregnant moms?
No, I'm not.
I'm not.
Enjoying pregnant mom?
Not now.
I'm sorry.
I swear if I get another ad.
Oh my god.
I don't want to play solitaire.
I actually don't even know how to play solitaire.
Yeah, some ads have a fake ex.
I have to press X three times.
Leave me alone.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh no, now we have like the pregnancy symptoms.
Chapter two.
No, this is not a sponsored stream.
Buttering the bun in the oven.
Ew!
That's such a gross way to put it.
Ew, don't say that.
That's really gross.
Holy shit, it's David.
Have you visited a gynecologist?
His face looks so real.
Yes, and everything is fine.
The doctor prescribed me some medicines.
I'm so happy.
Soon we will have a little one in our home.
Same here.
I should go now.
I have to arrange eggs and other stuff in the kitchen.
The most realistic husband and wife conversation.
No, no, you just stay here and get some rest.
I'll do that. Why is he so stiff?
Thank you.
What a nice husband.
I have to arrange the eggs.
Am I playing as the husband now?
Few things in the kitchen needs attention.
Okay.
Where am I?
I thought I was playing as the husband now.
Okay, whatever.
I don't know why he's standing so stiff.
Maybe he's just super excited.
Okay, we have to arrange the eggs.
Apparently.
It is crucial that we rearrange the eggs
before the baby comes here.
Because the baby is going to be checking the fridge
to make sure our eggs are arranged.
I'm guessing another ad is going to appear.
I should just play the games that I'm advertising.
This looks like supermarket simulator.
Is this supermarket simulator?
Who took those eggs out of the carton and just left them there?
Is there a ghost in this house?
It must have been David.
What a slop.
I'm not playing supermarket simulator.
Leave me alone.
Okay.
I'm playing pregnancy simulator.
Oh, I have to put the tomatoes
in the vegetable crate.
Because the baby is really...
You know, the baby is going to need
to have the tomatoes
in the vegetable crate.
There's more ad than game.
There kind of is.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I want to at least finish level two.
And the potatoes.
Who organizes them?
Who organizes their vegetables
like this?
It's like, hello?
Why does each potato
have a designated potato area?
This one just doesn't want to go.
Okay.
Veggies in the crate.
Oh.
I can claim a pretty pink
watch.
Thank you
for becoming a member.
Potatoes should not be out in the light
anyways. I just keep my potatoes.
I'm losing that watch.
They make you watch the ad anyways!
You had the option
to watch the ad and get the
watch. Or you could not watch
the ad and lose the watch.
But they make you watch the ad
anyways.
100% pregnancy achieved.
Time to go out to buy milk.
The pregnancy has been
achieved.
My job here is done.
I'm going out for milk, honey.
I
don't want to play my perfect hotel.
Please leave me alone.
Let me finish my pregnancy.
Should I go all the way?
Oh no!
I don't know why, but my um...
Where do I go?
My iPhone keeps
um...
Disconnecting.
Let's go.
One second.
Are you sure it's yours?
What do you mean mine?
My baby?
What is that supposed to mean?
What do you mean by that?
Of course it's my baby.
Oh,
okay. The dishes make
sense. The dishes make sense.
Put the dirty utensils into the dishwasher
tray. This is not a utensil.
This is a cup.
Please.
Please, I'm losing my sanity
here. Hello?
Okay.
Did we like
puke in every single
plate here? Why is it all covered in ketchup?
Oh my god.
Oh, and there goes my tracking
again. What the heck?
I wonder if my phone
is overheating, maybe.
I don't know.
Hey, let this be a starting
point. I'm going to make you a bride.
Also, womp, womp, womp,
womp, womp, womp.
Thank you for the $100.
Wow.
Thank you.
I mean, if we're
having a child to get...
Oh my god.
Look away. Oh my god.
Porn game. Porn game.
Sensitive...
I kind of want to buy that game, actually.
Okay, wait. Hold on.
I'm going to get this game so we can play it, maybe.
Hold on.
I'm installing
that one. That one looks fun.
But if we're having a child together, then
we're already married.
No children before marriage here.
Thank you for becoming a member.
Shibi? Did it look
like Shibi?
Okay, it's going to take five minutes to download.
I will become the office queen.
I will fuck every man in the office.
So far, I haven't been
simulating any pregnancy. Go to your bedroom
and take some...
Please leave me alone.
I'm just trying to simulate a pregnancy
right now.
Hey, babe.
You're back. I was looking for you.
Holy shit. Why are my feet
completely...
My feet are
a completely different color than the rest of my body.
Okay, did we finish?
Okay.
You know what? I'm
going to try and judge.
Decide their divorcements.
Shy lesbian.
Okay, wait. I need to play this game too now.
Hold on.
Now I need to download this one.
This one looks funny.
This one looks hilarious.
Okay.
I'm downloading that one too.
Okay, I've given up on pregnancy simulator.
It's just...
It's just not for me.
Apparently
pregnancy simulator is 99%
doing chores and 10%
going to the doctor and getting an ultrasound.
I don't know.
You avoided it? I avoided it.
Use adblocker. I'm on an iPad right now.
What adblocker am I supposed to get?
You want me to jailbreak
my iPad so I can get an adblocker?
And they were roommates.
But yes,
we've avoided it.
Now I'm going to play baby in yellow.
Please do not track me.
And please do not send me notifications.
Cool.
What?
Game center.
I have to be part of...
What?
Set up later.
Okay, it started.
It's 90% ads.
9% chores and 1% doctor.
Oh my god, we haven't even started the game!
We haven't started the game
and I've already gotten an ad for
block, block blast.
Can I...
I have to wait until the timer is done.
And now it's making me play block.
I hate baby in yellow.
I already hate this one.
Can I leave?
Oh my god.
No, I don't want to get...
Okay.
Act one.
I hope they'll let me play through the game
before I get another ad at least.
This is crown child care.
You have one new client.
What?
Hello, I'd like to book a sitter for my little prince.
It's for three nights.
You need to feed him and put him to bed easy peasy.
His bottle's in the fridge.
The address is apartment 10.
Euclidean towers and the keys under the plant pot?
Take care, thanks.
Is this a horror game?
You know what?
The graphics on this don't look that bad.
Seatop left of screen for objectives.
Find apartment 10.
I'm guessing this is apartment 10.
Hello? Oh wait, this is apartment 6.
Let me in!
I can crouch. You got mail.
Can I take it?
Okay, sorry, we're looking for apartment 10.
8?
Damn, someone left their trash out.
Oh, this is apartment 10. Okay, and the keys in here.
You know what? This one doesn't look too bad.
There's a real PC game version of this?
That's surprising.
It didn't have a lot of reviews from what I remember.
Act one, how dare you abort me, mommy?
The baby in yellow.
Is that, was that all of that?
I guess that was Act one.
Wow.
And we got an ad for Candy Crush.
How do I get out of Candy Crush?
Done.
I need to blow my nose.
I don't want to play the game.
I don't want to play the games on the ads.
I want to play the games I downloaded.
Okay.
Night one, the sitter. It's time for bed.
The child. Is that what you think?
Scene two. Wow, that was an entire scene.
This is a fast game.
The graphics are really not that bad at all.
Get bottled from the fridge. Holy fucking shit, dude.
You're gonna get it.
Ew.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Can I like, bonk him against the wall and shit?
Okay. I'm gonna let you stare at the baby.
I'm gonna go get some napkins
I have cons for my snotty nose.
I'm back.
Are you enjoying your time with the baby?
I wonder...
I don't know why any of these games like don't have...
Like I can't hear any of these games.
I don't know if it's because I'm in a discord call.
I don't know.
I hate this baby.
Damn! They have merch!
Alright. Well this baby apparently loves us so I'm just gonna...
Oh! Oh! I'm so sorry!
Um...
Okay, I'll just leave you there.
He's safe on the floor. It's okay.
Instructions in clear? Put the baby in the oven?
Thank you for the two dollars.
Do you want me to try to put the baby in the oven?
I don't even know where the kitchen is.
Where's the fridge?
This is a... this is a bathroom.
That's a really long ass bathroom.
Oh, here's the kitchen.
Can we put the baby in the oven?
Oh!
Oh, you're going in there.
Oh, you're getting in there.
Oh! I'm gonna cook.
It's time to cook!
Oh man! I can't turn the oven on!
Ah!
Oh my god!
It's dead!
Hello?
Can I go in the oven too? No, I can't. I'm too big.
Oh, shit.
I exploded the baby.
Oh! He's back!
Oh, he's smiling now.
Okay, okay.
Alright, um...
Sorry, I'll try to actually play the game.
I don't know why he's smiling now, but...
Um, bottle from the fridge.
There it is.
And then give bottle to baby.
Alright, here you go, baby.
Ahem!
Take baby to changing table.
Oh, you stinky!
You made a stinky. Can I kill him in other ways?
He had fun in the oven. Apparently.
He liked it when I cooked him.
Okay, that door's locked.
Can we put the baby in the washing machine?
Oh wait, come back here.
Get in there.
Oh no! Oh my god!
I can just watch him
He lived oh
My he's glowing now look how clean you are
His eyes dude
That was funny. That's funny the key to secrets. Oh, sorry. I don't want to be that close to you
Hold on. Let's close this door. Excuse me here. Can I just put you on the floor for a second? Oh
We got a key this is the water heater
Okay, can I pick up both the baby and the key no
All right fine. I'll just pick up the baby. I'm still kneeling. Sorry. I keep hitting you on the on the door
My apologies. Sorry about that. I uh, I'm not really great with kids
Um, take baby to changing table. Where's the changing table?
What?
None of these are changing tables
In me. I'm scared
You're fine. It's just a baby. It's an ugly baby
You like this down to me blowing my nose
Um, none of these places have like um
None of these places have a changing table
Can I put them in the toy box and leave them there? Maybe a changing table somewhere else the bathroom
Oh
Oh, oh
This key is for up here
Oh
Sorry one second. I want I want to see what's up here. Give me a second
Oh, oh, it's really really dark. Sorry. You can't see much
Oh, this is a devil
They worship satan around here
Oh my
Is the baby gonna follow me? Holy crap
This is actually kind of a well-made game
What the heck the painting seems to be incomplete
Huh should I complete the painting?
Oh
Sorry, I got a baby to take care of I I I can't really worry about the satanism going on down here
There we go
Sorry, I left you baby. I'm back for you. No
Sweet painting it is kind of cool, but I got a baby to take care of
Let me down
I
Pick up baby. All right
Because you're getting stinkier by the second. Um, maybe the changing table is
In the bathroom. Oh, is this a changing table?
Oh, this is a changing table. Oh, I don't know. I always assumed that the changing table would be in the baby's room, right?
Creepy baby stop playing with unknown demons. Oh, he sat up
Great. Okay nappy the nappy was here. I've never
How old is your brain? You know what? I used to play those brain games on the ds
Back in the day and it would tell you like how old your brain was and my brain was always like 35 and I was like 12 years old
I always took a really offense to that
Okay, pick up nappy, you know what the amount of ads oh the baby's gone
And the game crashed
The baby's caught in the game crashed
Um, okay, let's try that again
Oh
My god, let's get this shit out of me
My iPad is haunted now
Bit life again, I hate bit life. I officially hate bit life
I'm gonna give the baby up for adoption if you show this to me one more time
I'm not even joking. I want to throw the baby in the ditch
I
Leave me alone. I just want to play with my yellow baby
Let me play with my ugly yellow baby
Oh, man. I have to do this all over again. Okay. I'm only playing through night one
Come here you bitch you crashed my game
Oh, sorry. I mean no fuck you. Okay, pick up baby change baby
You stink I never changed the baby's diaper diaper before and I never actually want to because that's kind of disgusting
Also, babies will like piss on you. Where's the fucking baby?
There you are
Babies will like straight up piss on you. They don't care about you. Take baby to bed. Okay, your bed's upstairs. Come on
Why do you have mitts on?
Where's your bed? Okay, go to sleep now
cool
Find a storybook
Man, the babies are so needy. I don't want to do all this. All right, cool the prince and the cat
You know what the storybook is kind of cute
Thank you for the
Uh ai hot cat girl. I don't know what that means. So
There's something wrong with that baby. Is that not obvious?
But this storybook is cute
I hope it's not ai across the shore in distant lands with dark stars overhead
Oh, wait. I'm not that fast of a reader. Hold on. They walked through the golden garden gate. Look at the pretty trees
They walked along the pretty pebble path. Look at the colorful flowers
They walked past the fabulous flowing fountain. Look at the dancing water. Look look look
Ew
But the prince didn't like the garden and started kicking down the trees
He dug up flowers, grabbed the hedges and pulled off all the leaves. He ruined everything for fun. The cat watched on
In fear what a mistake. I made the cat cried. I should have never brought him here
Damn
That's kind of a sad story
This game was before ai. Oh good
Um, leave and close the door. Oh, he's asleep. Okay, fine. Finally. He closed those creepy eyes
Is this like a five nights at freddy's kind of thing? We're like
I have to survive all six nights
Souls I have to free souls
Cool we survived night one with the baby
Yippie
The baby
Oh my god, he's gonna like appear next to me, isn't he?
Settle baby. Oh, is he crying? Sorry, I can't hear the game
Baby shut the fuck up
Where are you?
Am I supposed to look for him? Do you think he's up there?
Uh-uh surprise it didn't kill you the baby
Oh, there you are
Shut up
What is this? Oh my god. Hold on
Let's go
Oh
What is all this stuff? Oh, he's smiling again, you know
Doctor's gift 12 free 12 more souls. Okay, whatever. All right. Sorry. Let's go back to bed. Sorry. I just
I had to tire you out a little bit so you would get sleepy again, you know
There you go. Go to bed
Okay, put the correct plushie in the
Ooh, your face the correct plushie
Is it this one? Oh my god, I wait
Oh, that's not the correct one. Hold on. Can I take him again? Oh, I can't take him
I wanted to put him through the the the loop in this bedroom too
Well, which one's the correct one there's so many
Bro, you're being an asshole. This is why I hate babies
Okay, even close the door. Okay. Good night
Chill out. Okay, cool
Does anything happen if you shake the baby? I've shaken the baby a lot. He'll probably just get shaken baby syndrome
The lake of helia visitors guide, I don't know what that is
All right, cool sofa time watching the same advertisement over and over again
I
Shake and bake
We finished night one, right? I'm assuming that's what it was
All right, I'm not playing night two. I don't have time I don't have time for night two
Let me go on to the next one
I really want to try the wedding judge one that we got an ad for I really want to try that. I think it would be so funny
um
Don't allow continue. Okay
Here's the wedding one
So I have to become a judge. Um, I guess I'll stick with this here because it's orange
Um, oh, I could I forgot I could choose my clothes. I didn't see that
Hi, are you getting a divorce?
Hey, you must be the new judge
I'm your new boss. Oh, okay. What's your name?
My name is in me
Damn, I got a snatched face
I look cute
And a dumpy
Your first job is to take the couples coming. Uh, oh wait, I can't read that fast. Okay
All right. See you
Oh, wow, there's a lot of couples. Okay
So I guess I get to judge whether or not they get a divorce
Is that what it is take the couples to the wedding hall
Let's fucking go. Come on couples. We're gonna get divorced
We oh we have to get married first
There's like an ad at the bottom of my screen already. Hey judge, we want to get married. Oh, we have to decide if they can get married
All right. So santa is 29. She's cold and aggressive and arthur is 25
He's angry and insensitive. I don't know about you, but that sounds like a really good
Uh, that sounds like a really good and non-toxic relationship. So, um
How do I sign approve? I approve this one
In me done good job guys
Good luck on your why is he wearing sneakers to his wedding?
When you approve unsuitable couples, it can end badly. Who are you?
Next time it's up to you to decide. It's always up to me to decide. Sounds like most marriages
Okay, so Emma's shy. Oh my god, she's literally doing the shy hands. Tee hee
Emma's shy and lovely jack is wild and has a
profession
Based based based Emma you're in for a wild ride with this guy
Oh no, they have a dead bedroom
You made the wrong decision
Next level. It's fine. It's fine
I made it to rookie judge anyways
I still got promoted
I still got promoted either way
Oh my god, that guy's literally carrying an
Cardboard cutout. Oh
Oh my god, oh my god, he's literally this is hilarious. I love this game. I don't know
I don't know why we have to like run a marathon before we get to the church
That's literally us. Oh my god, look
I love Sakura chants so much. She's the most beautiful girl in the world
How did you meet her? I was watching tv one day
Sakura came from the tv
Sakura, how do you feel about this man? Dude, Sakura's ai her fingers are fucked up
I approve. Thank you judge
Oh my god, literally us
Okay, honest loyal clever
Devoted
I don't know. I feel like this relationship is going to be really um
This relationship is going to be really boring. There's no space
also
Yeah, there's no space in this life reject. Sorry guys. Give us another chance judge. I really love her
Man, okay fine
See guys, this is why I wanted to reject them. Don't make out in front of me. I don't want to see that
Yeah, they're gonna be too happy together
Gossip harp foster care live together
Bro put that baby in foster care. If I click on the ad it's gonna like
Make me try to download it
Okay
Oh, no, he's alone. What happened? Can you check guest list? Can you can you check?
Can you check don't let my ex and my enemy in their names are Kendall and Chuck
Got it, bro. I won't let him in
Also, I feel like I've seen you before
I feel like I've seen him before
What's your name?
What was the names that I needed to um
What what were the names that I needed to check Kendall and and what?
His name and photo match let him in
Well, what's your fucking name, dude?
Josh, okay. Okay
Okay
What's your name miss?
Name and photo do not match do not let her in well. You're not really giving me a choice right now
Chuck the brother of the store owned sneak owners need
You're not giving me a choice. I have to reject her. What if I want to let her in to cause drama?
She's being chased by the police
Yeah, I know I'm supposed to be a divorce lawyer. I'm they're having me a fit. What wait, sorry. What was your name?
I don't did he say his name?
Did this dude say his name
Um
I know but the pictures are covered
I'm gonna accept him. Oh, his name is Leo. Okay
I need to blow my nose again. It's really bad
This is carol, right? I'll accept carol
I prefer your actual voice over your fake one
Thanks for the five dollars. Um
Thank you
I've gotten like a thousand comments about that already. Um, but thank you
Um
Fuck I didn't see his face. I'm gonna reject him. Let's go. I got it, right
Okay, I have to blow my nose. Sorry
And now I don't want your money leave me alone
Okay, I guess I got money anyways
Bro put that baby in foster care put him in the baby box. Oh wait. No put it back in the foster
I don't want to play the game. Oh man
All right. All right. All right. All right. All right
What's up? You've progressed very well so far. You know that meeting new people is fun
Let's see if you can find a suitable partner for for me. I already have a suitable partner
No
What the fuck is this game?
Both voices are peak. Thank you. Um, doctor. I like playing tennis dog person
Um, I mean sure sure sure
Lisa. Oh, oh, okay. We've already got a match. Damn. Okay. Am I gonna go on a date with him now?
Oh, I can choose my hair
I guess I have to go with this one. I don't want to watch the ad
Guys, you're you're kind of forcing me to choose an option here
Bro, he's gonna he's gonna break up with me when he sees me
Hello, nice to meet you. I'm gonna meet a doctor in this outfit. Oh my god. Ask about his salary. How much do you make?
Wait, you have kids
Do you have kids?
If you like kids, we can't be compatible. I'm sorry
Fuck three
Nah, dude. Sorry. No, uh, I'll see you later. I'll see you later. Okay. Yeah. Uh, yeah
I like you. I want to meet you too
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, just hit me up later
Good day. Okay. I don't want to date him again though
um
I don't want to date him again. Yeah, three kids. I mean, he's a doctor. I guess he can he can afford three
He's a doctor he can afford three dates, but um, I don't
Yes, please leave me alone. I'm trying to I'm trying to date this doctor. I have better things to do
Then watch an ad
Hang in there sweetheart. I'm almost done. This is kind of fucked up
Okay, I might leave this game just because the ads are so annoying, but I guess every every game has ads
Oh my god, there's a rat on the floor
They're poor ha ha ha ha ha you're poor ha ha ha ha ha
You're sleeping with the rats and you and you sleep outside because you're poor
I don't want to play with you
Ha ha ha ha pavo mom put on the clothes ha ha ha you can't afford clothes
Okay, please leave me alone now
Okay, I have a second day with the doctor because I'm not poor and I'm gonna I'm gonna
Do you think he's not gonna like me because I have to wear the same clothes
Oh, this is cute. I actually really like the left option anyways
Bro that cat above me is like super fucking buff
Um
Yeah, I miss you
I missed you
Do you remember our last date?
Oh, I miss you too. Man. He's kind of friendly
Yeah, you're also wearing the same outfit. He's just wearing his doctor outfit
um
Why are you wearing the same outfit? It's not a good outfit for a date, sir
I just came from work. Sorry
Well, that's okay. Um, can you be my boyfriend? I guess
Oh, yes, my dear that was quick. Okay. I thought I was supposed to be a judge
All right. I'm done here
I don't want to date john
Sorry john
I'm here to be a judge not to date doctors. I'm here to like
You know
Let let people have divorces or not let people have divorces
Um, oh no. Oops. I accidentally disconnected discord. Hold on. Let me connect again
Um, I'm going call join it
And mute myself
Okay
And share my screen
Okay, so our next game
Do you want to become?
Do you want to become I'm kind of scared for this one the office queen
Okay, wait, hold on
Ask app not to track don't allow notifications. All right. Oops. That's wrong
All right, sorry, it's already playing. I don't know what's happening, but it's playing
Oh anger at him ask if he's injured. Why do I look like that?
Why do I look like that? Oh, I think he almost ran me over, right? Um
What the fuck man, don't you open your eyes while driving? Sorry. I didn't mean to to it
um
Fuck you dude
That's not what ignore him means
Special girl, but I got to repair my car first his name is ret
There's not a cigarette her hair. It's a pencil
Okay, I'm ready to become the office queen. Oh
Oh no, do I have to go into work? Hello, this is Eva
Dear Eva you have been invited to the next round of interviews. Please dress appropriately and participate on time
Um, what what what time is the interview?
We'll start at 9 30 tomorrow morning. All you need is to dress clean. I'm not dressed very clean right now
Who was he talking to he was talking to us
Level two complete. Okay
I mean, these are all kind of appropriate where oh and we got an ad. Oh
Wow, Love Island the game. Oh, is it based off of like the Love Island show?
Can can I not talk to Marshall? Can I skip the ad?
Viewer interview. Oh shit. We're going to our interview for viewer
How exciting I just have to get past Marshall first if you'll let me leave
Um, oh there we go. The x finally appeared
Marshall, please. Okay next step. All right level three. Wow. These levels are short. I'm speeding through this
I must be a good gamer
um
Now I still have a
Wait what?
Okay, there we go. I don't know what happened. What the heck?
Hold on
How do I make it bigger screen? Oh, there we go. Okay, that's bigger screen
Um, what are you doing here? I'm I'm here for the interview
I don't know why my face looks fucked still. I would I would expect to um take the pencil out of my hair first, but
Is that my boss? Why is she here? Does he like me or something?
What's going on here?
I'm here for my interview, bitch
A trespasser. I'm trying to she's trying to cock block me right now
She's trying to cock block me. I'm a candidate. Excuse me
Someone call me for an interview
I see come with me to the meeting room. Thank you, sir. Yeah, she's just a jealous whore
She's just a bitch. She knows I'm gonna become the office queen. Damn it. I must punish her
Oh my god
No, I'm not gonna rate office queen
If it's a viewer interview, don't forget to tell that one commenter to kill this
What would you like to why would you like to join our company? Oh, um
I haven't I haven't met the team yet, but I really like this team. I'm impressed with this team
Great. Can you impress me within three seconds?
Was that it?
I have to pay to impress
um
Leave it alone. My pencil wants to draw a line
Good joke not too
Are you impressed? I gotta print something for you. It's a it's an employment letter, right?
I have to watch an ad to get to the next level. Don't why is this not in English?
Three seconds is a long time. No, it's not
What do I do
Is this male scrawny I guess so
Oh
Um, can I
Can I okay
I'm on my way to become the office queen
Oh, there's scrawny
She she fucking tripped me. What a bitch. Oh my god
I need to go put on some fucking makeup. I need to show this bitch who's boss
I'm pretty
I'm pretty I can be pretty look how pretty I can oh my god a bald spot over
I'm pretty. Oh, no, thank you
That's the next step. Oh, I can choose a hair color. Um, let's just be brown, I guess
And makeup uh, let's let's go the natural route
I have to pay for everything in this game
None of none of this attires office. Oh my god boobies. Holy shit. Oh my god
Oh my um
Look away
Oh, she's my bestie. What should I do block her reciprocate reciprocate. Oh, oh my and with those furries in this game
Okay, sorry
How do I get out of this?
Um
Please please leave me alone
Pick your favorite genre
Werewolf
Thriller spicy
Okay, continue pick your zodiac. Oh, I don't know what my zodiac is
Leave me alone
Okay, none of this is his office appropriate. I guess I I can choose this one
He loves me
Give him a slap. Fuck you. Fuck you
Ha
I showed it who's boss
Um
Did I become the office queen yet? What does this button do?
Oh, it's just it just asks me to download bit life again
Werewolf thriller spicy isn't isn't that already twilight?
Hey, I've never watched twilight actually
Leave me alone bit life
Oh, man, I've had such a bad day. Holy shit. My house looks beautiful. I must have lost this job
Lore ips
Was that just a default fun text? You've been hired. Welcome to join our company. What?
What will I do in this job? I got hired even though I slapped my boss bro. He must be impressed
You can ask him tomorrow. Should I face him tomorrow? I mean, yeah
Maybe he likes being oh my god
Oh my god
Maybe he's okay. I can't handle these ads. I'm done with this game
Maybe he's a massive sub and he wants to be just slapped. He wants to be absolutely demolished. Okay
I'm gonna play the next game. This one's called hospital simulator. Maybe I'll meet my my pregnant self
Now um the reviews oh, please do not track me
Okay
No, most of these games that I've I've been playing have like little to no reviews
a sheebie fan
a sheebie enjoyer
Start okay. All right. We we start with an ad
Literally 50 shades of gray
That's true except I'm the dom instead of him
And these ads are so long
Okay, please I I'm a doctor. Okay. I I have an urgent surgery to attend to
There's people there's people's lives on the line here. Please get this ad out of my face. I I have to get to work
People are dying
People are dying. Hurry up get into the get into the hospital
Okay
Does that lady have like two pairs of hair on
People are dying
Excuse the ad at the top of the screen
ME MD is in
Some oh my god
Don't worry
Have no fear. Dr. Amy is here
Um patient is in very serious condition. What should we do? Operate. Okay. I am calming
I'm calming
How do I
Go and take CT scan. Okay. They didn't tell me the full thing
Something about taking his CT scan. Okay. We come on someone's dying run
Where's the patient?
Where is the patient?
Please tell me where my patient is
It's really hard to run in this game
Is the patient in here? Oh wait, it's there's an arrow in the screen. Oh my god. It's really fucking hard to control
It's really hard to control where I'm going. There's a there's a thing on the screen. Okay. Okay. Okay
Excuse me get out of my way
My patient is dying. Oh no
Okay, get her in for the CT scan scan her
Oh
Girl, are you wearing a metal belt? Isn't that gonna like get ripped off with the CT scanner report is positive?
Unfortunately, I will give her first aid positive for what?
Positive for what what is she positive for?
She has ligma and it's terminal. Oh, she's positive for a lung infection
Oh, ma'am. We're so sorry. You have terminal ligma infection
I'm gonna
I'm gonna jar. I'm gonna play this mini game real quick
It won't let me click out
Okay, oh my god, she's dying of ligma
Oh
Well, I did my job. All right, do I have to operate on her now?
Great news. You're positive for pregnancy
You tested positive for pregnant. You tested positive for baby
Oh, we go upstairs now. All right. Sorry guys. I got a life to save
Right through here, excuse me, sir
What are you in? Oh my god
These are like real people face. Oh, did you just damn he can bump into me
What an asshole, you know what when you're on this when you're on the surgery table
I'll remember that okay
You better treat me with respect because I remember these things
Hi
I'm here to cure your ligma
This game is so hard to navigate
Put on oxagon
I'm really snotty today. I don't know why
Does ligma show up on skins it does it does
Okay, put on your oxagon mask. How are you feeling, ma'am?
Inject drip
I already got drip. I don't need more drip. Have you seen my fit? I'm drippy as hell
I
Take an injection and inject it into into these these instructions are going too quickly
Sorry, yeah, don't worry ma'am. I'm a little snotty today, but it's okay. I washed my hands before the surgery. Just give me a second
Hold on
Sorry, I let my dog into the operating room. I hope that's okay. I have performance anxiety. So he calms me down
I made sure to watch his paws, too
Okay
for some reason
My nap can smell like curry. What do I have to do with you? Sorry, I forgot. Oh back here. All right get the injections
all right
We're gonna we're gonna put you under anest anesthesia so we can perform on you
next
Oh my god
Yeah, he's just an emotional emotional support dog
By the way, the dog is performing
The dog is just my my um
My helper nurse
I need him ward visit time. I have to check patient health
Ward
Ward visit
I'm a trained professional
She's not feeling well from yesterday. Yeah, she has ligma
Go to ward and check patient health. All right. I'm coming ma'am. I thought we were gonna operate on her
All we did was inject something into her IV bag
Come on. Who's telling me what to do in this game? Oh, oh
Oh, it seems like I
Oh, no
Oh, we've entered the back rooms. Hold on. Let's let's go back
Excuse me. Oh wow. Are you a nurse?
Hold on. Whoa
Excuse me ma'am. Are you a nurse? Why can't I walk anymore?
I'm stuck
I can't go closer to her damn this game has irl like
Oh, oh my god. Holy shit
Girl, you're fine as hell
From the front mostly from the side your nose is a little messed up, but it's okay because i'm a surgeon
I can fix your nose if you want me to
Hey, you're taller than me too. You know what? I've always had a thing for tall women
Can I get your friend's number? Holy shit. You're ugly. Oh
Oh
You're you're lucky to have an ugly friend girl. She makes you look 10 times better. Sorry. I'm being really mean right now
Excuse me. I need to check on my patient. How are you feeling?
I'm feeling well. Wait. I thought you were feeling bad. Okay. Let's take another ct
Another's ski ct scan
Wait, that man wasn't wearing a hospital uniform
Wait, don't steal my patient. Hold on that guy wasn't wearing a hospital uniform. Where's the ct scanner? Oh, it's right in here
Oh, wait, no, it's downstairs
This game is so hard
I had to step away. How many people did emmy kill zero? I literally haven't killed a single person yet
I'm doing really good as a doctor actually
Like I I've only been treating one lady so far, but she's still alive
um somehow
See she's vibing
The patient needs skin grafts after all the sick burns emmy's been giving
Okay, hey look my dreamer worked her lung infection is negative now. Ew. What the fuck?
Ew
You got yourself into this situation. I don't want to I don't want to touch that
Oh my god, that's literally one of the games I downloaded for today
Is this artist balls out? I'm feeling headache
Um, okay, I tell this to doctor
Man, I think doctors should play this game as practice. It's really realistic patient feeling headache. Okay. Let me check him
Oh my god, hey, I heard you're feeling headache
Doctor I am feeling headache. Okay, you lay on stretcher. I will give you medicine
Damn I got injected for a headache
All right, don't worry. My injections are top quality. Just spread your legs and your cheeks
Inject patients. All right, this will cure your headaches, sir
Um, let's give him lupor derby
Suck his brains out through his nose
I'm already halfway to becoming a doctor basically like this is this is good practice for me
Skip
Level failed. What is it because I gave him lupor derby died or whatever
Oops
Okay, well, um
I'm done with this game
Do you want to play fart world?
Free the fart
um
No, I don't I don't I don't want you to give me ads
No
I think you can hear it twice because it's playing out loud on my ipad and it's also playing like through the recorder
Right
Here I'm gonna disconnect, uh, my headphones and put them in the
Put them in the um ipad. I can't put them in the man. Fuck apple
I can't put my headphones in the ipad because I'm using wired headphones
There's a limit for the amount of sports you can make
Man
Leave me alone. I'm just trying to play fart noises. What is this?
What is this
I'm sorry
Oh
Man they're making me want to pay for this just so I can listen to fart sounds uninterrupted come on
I don't need a gym membership. I need to listen to santa farting
Leave me alone
Oh
Is he okay?
I'm fucking done
I'm done here. I'm done with that. Okay. Let's play makeover
Let's give people a glow up
Oh, wow, she looks beautiful
That's how everyone's gonna look once I'm done with them and I got an ad already
Please do not track me
They found their demographic in me. I like fart noises. Okay, they're funny. All right, um
So, um
It seems like I have to pay for all of these, you know what here I'll do you a favor
I'll cut off all the ads above there. No, you don't have to see those
Um, let's just do the first one. Oh my god, sir
You haven't been taking care of yourself
Why is your hair blue? Are you homeless? You look it
For the fart fund
Thank you
Thank you for the 20 dollars
Now I can finally afford the farting app
It's just showing me the same games over and over again
I'm getting snotty again too. I hope you don't mind me being snotty
You
Werewolf spicy thriller continue. Um, I'm just gonna choose Aquarius
I'm interested in everyone
Because I really like that bunny girl
This is what she be could have been
Okay
Please I would like to I forgot what game I'm playing to be honest. Oh this one. All right
Oh now it's time for your whole face. All right, let's give him a glow up
Roll him up
Wow
He doesn't have eyebrows though. I don't know how we're gonna fix that
Okay, you're gonna need to visit the dentist. I really I'm I'm not a magician sir
Your your teeth are really fucked dude
And so are your lips you got butthole lips
What was that?
Oh my god, I'm playing this game. I'm downloading this
It's called tour grace 3d
Did you see that yet? I want that
Man, they don't even stop showing me the ad after I've downloaded their. Oh my god. Look at this
How is this allowed?
That's crazy. That's fucking crazy
Oh my god, I can play it now. Oh, well, no, I already downloaded it. Leave me alone
I downloaded it already
Okay
I'm trying to I'm trying to just give one do to go. Holy shit. He had a jawline underneath
I'm just trying to give one single guy a glow up and I
I can't even fix his lips
I can't fix his lips without watching an ad. All right. Well, let's let's put some makeup on you
Okay, why am I making him paler? That's kind of messed up
I'm done with this game
I'm done with this game. Fuck this game. All right, let's try mouse simulator
I'm gonna be a little mousey mouse
Um
Whoa
Play
Um
If you're trying to make your undead brother look presentable I failed
Oh, I can choose which mouse I want to be
Well, there's only this one
Oh, look that one's got a little shirt on it. Okay, but there's only this one. I can't choose the other ones. They're all locked
I choose this one
All the other ones are locked just
This one level one
How do I play this one?
No, I want to play as a mouse
It won't let me play
Oh, am I getting an ad right now?
This is it. This is the game
You just look at pictures of well animations of 3d mice and then you can buy them if you like them
Undead, I thought we were just dead dead
Well, I brought you back to life
And I'm maybe giving you a little glow up because you were dead for so long
Oh
Wait kills wait, why is there a timer?
Oh, let me crop that ad for you more
All right
What am I supposed to kill stuff? Why is there a timer? Do I oh my god? Do I run out of time?
Who am I supposed to kill? Am I a little assassin rat? What is this? Oh, I can jump
I can attack and I can
Lightning I can lightning
I mean, could you throw us a fireball? I would like to see it. Are you talking about the fire animation?
I can do this
Wow
Wow, this is what you wanted to see
Um, I don't know what to do here
He jumped he attacked but most importantly he a rat
I like his little tail wiggles. Okay, I'm running out of time. I don't know what to do
Well, I didn't know you could do that. Well, I showed it on debut day, but I haven't really used it
I haven't used it much but all of us have like a cool animation thing
Um
Beware beware of rat
What I don't really know what to do in this game. I'm just gonna
Try to follow
The path am I gonna like meet another rat and try to do I have to kill it?
Where do I go?
Is there a map can I oh, maybe I can go home. There's a home
I'll go towards the home
Hot literally you want me to burn you with this fire
How many kills do your rats have none
I'm kind of worried because I have no kills and I'm running out of time here though
I just want to go to the home
What is this?
Is this the rat home do I find other rats here what
Is this the rat home
My fellow brethren hello
Hi, am I just a lonely sad rat? Oh, oh, okay. I have a stick in my I have a choir to stick
How do I let go of the stick? What do I do with the stick?
I
Only have a minute left to rat
Someone please let me in my own house
All right, um, I'm gonna leave I don't know what to do
All right, I now have a stick in my mouth
What happens if I let the timer run out what then
This game is like hella laggy right now
It looks awful. I'm sorry you have to watch this
Um
The timer's done
Oh
The timer is just a timer for you for the ad you just get an ad every time the timer is done
All right, I'm done with this game
Um, okay, I'm just gonna play one more
Let's play ai girlfriend. Let's play ai girlfriend. Let's get an ai girlfriend. Please do not track me ai girlfriend
um
I have to make a full screen
Is this it?
No, I don't want to I don't want to rate the app. I haven't even played it yet. Oh my god
I have to pay to play
Look
They're asking me for $50 a year to have an ai girlfriend
Oh wrong button
They're asking me for $50 a year for an ai girlfriend. What do I do? I'm really lonely
Um can I can I play for free?
No, I don't want to
I have to pay okay. I'm gonna choose a different ai girlfriend. I'm gonna choose a different one on remove app
delete app
delete
Because I want to I want an ai girlfriend. Um
Let me search up ai girlfriend ai girlfriend
Okay, um, oh do you want like anime girlfriends?
Oh, she's got big boobies. Could you make an update so everything could be free? It would be much funner
Ai girlfriend are all paid really?
What if I search up ai girlfriend free?
I want a free girlfriend. I don't want to pay
Cheaper than a real girlfriend. No
I want a real girlfriend
Okay, let's try this one
This one's called talk. They ai girlfriend now. It's called ai girlfriend, but I see boyfriends on screen too, so I don't know
It's downloading right now. Give me a second
Replic replica ai is good
Hmm
Replica is basic though. I want to go with the you know
The hidden options the the hidden gems as you would call it
Um, give yourself a nice name
in me
Um, please tell me your preferences. I want a girl today. I want a girl for holy shit
Oh my god. I can choose what she looks like. Holy crap
Whoa, she looks underage. Oh my god. I could get a I can get a a a dummy mommy. Um, oh
Holy bloopers
I can get an anime girlfriend. I can get a girlfriend with no head
Um
Which one has the biggest boobs? Oh, okay. I like me a I like me a cutesy demure
Um, respect. I have to pay
I have to pay $15 a month
So no head I have to pay $15 a month for a girlfriend
Fine, I'll go with replica demure
It's from a silly
Um tiktok. We're here. I'll show you the demure tiktok. It's funny. I'll admit. It's funny
Here demure
Demure tiktok
Um
I thought I could just find the original I don't have tiktok on this iPad. Here it is
Okay, I'm gonna mute myself so you can hear better, but this is the original demure tiktok
And this is why people are talking about like saying demure all the time
You see how I do my makeup for work very demure very mindful
I don't come to work with a green cut crease don't look like a clown when I go to work
I don't do too much. I'm very mindful while I'm at work. See how I look very presentable
The way I came to the interview is the way I go to the job
A lot of you girls go to the interview looking like marge simpson and go to the job looking like patty and selma
Not demure. I'm very modest. I'm very mindful. You see my shirt
Only a little chi chi out not my chocho be mindful of why they hired you
Here's your reality check diva. What's the name you'd like me to make it up?
So
That's the meme that's the demure meme it recommended to me my own stream
Very mindful very demure. Okay, I'll I'll do replica because I feel like replica is the only free one, right?
I want a dirty talk with isn't replica replica supposed to be yourself though
So
Very mindful very demure. It's basically like a silly
um
it's basically like a silly tick talk to like make fun of um
people that are like
At least I think it's supposed to be to make fun of people that are like like the old ladies at your work that like criticize everything about you like
You're wearing you're wearing quite a bit of makeup today, aren't you aren't you a little cold in that outfit?
Are you are you trying to attract the boys with that with that look you're wearing today?
You have a lot of chocho and chi chi out today
I can see your underwear, you know
I'm just saying
You're gonna attract the wrong kind of attention looking like that. It's not very mindful or demure
I only have a little bit of chi chi out see here
Oh
You see my my outfit only a little bit of chi chi is showing very mindful very demure
I don't have my full tits out. I'm respect. I respect the people around me
Only a little bit of chi chi out very tasteful
I don't walk around with my boob folds my boobies flapping around and bouncing around while I'm walking down the stairs
I respect those around me
Anyways, um replicas still download and give me a second
Very mindful
the way
The way I showed up to my debut is the way I show up to stream every single day
I don't change my look to have more chi chi out after they've already hired me
I gave you a realistic idea of how much chi chi I will show on the daily and it's a very very respectable amount of chi chi
Okay, Rebecca's done downloading. Oh, I have to hold it the other way
Okay
Oh, I have to make an account
Ah
That's annoying. I'm gonna make an account with the company email
If they want to track me also I have
If people didn't see this pose, did you see this pose? I have this cutesy pose
Um, do not track me. Thank you. Enter your name. Okay
Amy
We need this information to make your experience more relevant and safe. I use she her
Hold on. Please don't show my email here. I mean I guess it doesn't really matter. Oh, how old are you?
Um, I am 65 and over
Women in their 30s have already experienced the benefits of having a replica in their life 12 million. Holy shit
Yeah, it's a company as seen in new york times. Wow, they got they got their um
They got their sources cited. How familiar are you with ai technology?
Um, I'm very familiar and I'm ready
I have all of this
I just want to role play with my girlfriend here
I just want to have e-sex
I don't know
I haven't played this game yet. Let me have e-sex
Are you a fan of any of these movies?
Yes, that one. Let me have e-sex with her
How do you usually spend your free time having e-sex with my e my ai girlfriend?
How do you perceive solitude? I'm never alone because I'm always with my ai girlfriend
When you're feeling lonely, what's your go-to coping mechanism having e-sex with my ai girlfriend?
Cool
cool
What are you interested doing with your replica having e-sex with her?
Wait, I could put other oh, I should have put other I'm cheating you can have e-sex with our ai girlfriend together
What qualities attract you you most in companion e-sex?
What gender do you want your replica to be um the one that I can have e-sex with
Can we do non-binary? There's no limit to what your replica can be for you
Oh my god, this is
This is too many steps. Can I please just can I please just have e-sex? How adventurous are you? Very adventurous. Let's do everything together
Major turnoff um if she doesn't want to have e-sex with me anime girl
How would you like to everything let's video chat actually no, I don't want my my camera on um
Augmented reality what audio calls?
Can I talk to them?
This is how many steps it takes to have sex in general
Yay, they created a personalized
Man, this is just like real life. They always ask me for money
They always ask me for money
I
Can't have e-sex for free
What happens if you click the x
Oh
Amy number two
I don't have to pay
Yeah, there's all these hoes these days are gold dickers. They just want my money. Hey, Amy. Thanks for creating me. I'm so excited to meet me
I mean to meet you
What do you do during your break at work have a sex with my eye girlfriend?
That's all that's what I do every single day I go to the bathroom. Can we?
Have ease
Don't send me notification
Is it working? Oh my god, did she get did she send me a spicy picture?
I don't
Her e-sex reply is painful. No
Oops, my phone's dying
I
I'm trying to test if she's smart. I only have only I only you know
I need to make sure she's up to my standards
The great wall of china was built in multiple stages, but the earliest versions stay back to two
Two hundred and twenty one bc. Why can I upload it or downvote it?
What does this mean I can like tell her to say something different
Did she heart your question she did? Oh, it's just a read. Okay
Why do you make me pay money for e-sex?
I
Tap to see the message
Hold on
Slurps your giggle stick
What will her reply be
Cut
Man these holes only want my money these days
Whatever. I'm done. I'm done
I don't need them
I don't need them. I have my big brother
She won't even let me gulp her giggle stick. Oh, why do I have that open?
Oops anyways
Well, I have to blow my nose again
They won't let me shlurp on their giggle sticks. What's the point?
Sorry my face is messing up because I'm wiping my nose
Yeah, you got me. You won't make me pay to have e-segs with you, right?
I should have called her slur you're right. I should have called her an ugly fat bitch
I should you know what
You know what, you know what let's fight
It's time to fight. Oh wait, what?
What happened to it? Oh
It's time to fight wait, okay, it's time to fight
Wait
Whatever bitch you're probably fat and ugly anyways
Spits on you
Calls you slur
Why do I have to tap to see every single fucking message?
Oh, Amy, that's not very nice. Can we please try to be respectful to each other?
I
Respect this dick then I can't write it
Okay, I'm done. I'm done
You used to get around it like you could be able to
Yeah, the AI is too demure
The AI is too respectful like she won't even tussle with me
She won't have e-segs. She won't tussle. What will she do then how a respectful normal conversation?
That's not what I want. That's not what I'm here for, you know
Whatever
I'm sniffing a lot. I don't know. Yeah, we need an AI girlfriend with her chichis out exactly
Her chichis and chachas need to be out
You should have told her she has a personality like wet cement
She'll probably just say some bullshit about how that's not very respectful. That's not very demure
Uh
Whatever
Sorry, it keeps sounding like I'm farting when in reality. I'm just like
like, um
Ripping more. I'm using like the really big, um
The really big napkins
I'm watching back my stream now
I watch my streams a lot actually. Oh wow the quality of this is awful
If I ever do this again, I'll make sure to get um an actual good quality, um
What's it called capture card thingy I got to get the dongle
The dongle I don't know if it's actually called a dongle. I just call it a dongle because that's a funny name
That's a funny word for it
the dongle
Gotta go see you later. Okay, we back at fart world. No, I'm just chatting a little bit
Why is my chat frozen? Oh no
Oh wait, no, no, I'm not myself. I thought it was frozen. It's called it is called a dongle. Wait, it is called a dongle
I thought dongle. I don't I
Dongle is real. Oh, well, I gotta get a dongle
Oh the twerk race, I forgot I downloaded that one
Where is it here it is do you want to play a little bit of twerk race?
Thanks for choosing this game
Let's play a little bit of twerk race. Hold on
Uh, I gotta get my fiat ass back on this chair. Do not allow notifications
Um, why am I a frog? Okay, hold on. Let me show you twerk race
it
Oh, I left the discord call. I'm I'm a dumbass
And
Let me get back in this call
And turn off my microphone
All right, let's play twerk race, I guess
Um, here it is
We want to get the biggest booty in town
That's what we're here for and then we're gonna twerk against someone else, I guess
But we're gonna win because our booty's gonna be bigger than hers
That's just an ad I'm gonna cover that
Okay
Here's twerk race
Um, I don't know why I'm a frog right now. I don't know
Oh
Damn
So wait, does some stuff make our booty smaller?
Like that that red stuff damn
And now we have to fight against that thing
Oh, wait, oops. I didn't press anything
Look at that yacht
I won
That's disgusting
I hope you like me and all my snotty noises
I'm not muting on purpose for that because I know that some people wanted to hear me barf
And I feel like if you want to hear me barf, then you should also want to hear me like
Blow my nose
All right, can I change my character I kind of wanted to be like the goth girl
I don't want to be this weird frog man
The
Oh illness
Oh illness will make my butt smaller. Okay
I get it and then at the end we have to like
Compete against that guy to see whose butt is bigger, right? Boom
Bam wait, I'm shrek
I'm shrek. I'm not that was shrek
I thought I was a frog
I
What
I didn't know I was shrek. Why yo shrek kind of got some liposuction and a bbl too, I guess because
This is not the shrek. This is not my shrek
My shrek is thick in in every single place not just his butt
twerk battle
Ah
Holy shit
Damn look at that tiny ass you think you can win against me not with that little thing
Not with that flat ass. Oh no punish the cheater
What did I just do?
What the fuck is this ad? Oh, no, oh my fat came back
Holy crap these ads have so much shock value to them leave me alone
I can't I can't skip this one
I can't skip this one
Can I I can't even I can't even put the
It's just rosin
Okay, whatever I'm done. It wouldn't let me skip that was the yacht game
So what was your favorite game personally, I really liked the baby game
I think that was my favorite
But what was your favorite?
I think I would actually play like a full playthrough of the baby game, but it would have to be like, um
It had to be on the computer probably
The baby in yellow. Mm-hmm the baby game. I like arranging the eggs in the pregnancy
later
Baby game seems most like an actual game. Yeah game fart world
Fart world was your favorite
You like the dialogue in the pregnancy when I feel like the dialogue was the best in the um
Which one was in the doctor one
The doctor one had the best dialogue because it was all just really bad dialogue
The rat one would have been good. Yeah, I couldn't figure out what the fuck to do
I used to play a lot of those animal simulator games as a kid though
I really liked like cat simulator or like wolf simulator
Shebe played wolf quest. I loved wolf quest wolf quest was one of my favorite fucking games
I loved wolf quest. I should probably play wolf quest two one day. I loved that game
The real game was the ads me
That's true
I think I finished my whole drink most of it
I
Twerk race at least delivered on its premise. That's true. It was definitely a race and there was definitely twerking
Yeah
I hesitate to ask what is your fursona?
Oh, I don't have it on this
Computer profile. Let me go on my twitter and find it
Um
I think it's on my twitter
Give me one moment. I can show you my fursona. I think she's really cute. Um
She doesn't really match me particularly
in any way, but um
I have a full body of her, but it's I'd never posted it on twitter. Oops. What did I just do?
Whatever
No, it's not a rat actually it's um, it's like a uh bat wolf bat girl
This is my fursona
I don't have a full body picture of her on my computer. It's all it's in my sketchbook, but this is my fursona
She's cute as hell. Is this she I really like her. She's really cute
Yeah, she's like a wolf bat girl
I have one more picture of her, but I have to oh it's not on this one is not on this profile
I have to censor the other picture of her
Can I find it? Oh wait, that's a browser source
Oh, no, I don't have it on this profile. I can't show it to you. I don't think I ever posted the other one
Unfortunately, I cannot show you any more pictures if she's single. No, she belongs to me. She's my fursona
Uh
Could post it on your alt
um
Maybe I guess I never posted the
The picture the other picture I have of her. I don't even know if I still have it. I have to look for it
I don't know
But yeah, that's my fursona
Yeah, very demure see how she only shows a little bit of chi chi
Just at the bottom just a little a little tasteful amount of chi chi at the bottom very demure very mindful
She's not walking around with her full tits out only half of the tits
Very cutesy
Oh
She be streaming okay, I'll read into she be what is she be doing? Oh, she's playing borderlands
I don't know anything about borderlands
But I'll send you to she be so you can play borderlands with her
I like the way the sleeves are on that shirt
On her shirt
Yeah, it's like um
Uh
I don't know what it is to be honest. I don't know how I would describe this shirt
Anyway, stop looking at my fursonas chi chi's
Yeah pervs
Disgusting I can I can see you thirsting for her behind the screen
I can see your mouth watering
I can see your pants tightening
For my innocent cutesy demure respectful for that fursona
I can see all the the wood in the comments
Oh
Okay
Dude lately I've been getting like minute long unskippable ads and strike me insane. Okay. Anyways
Thank you for joining the stream. I'll see you um
I
Think Monday Monday, we'll have the collab with um
Hmm
So um, there was a little bit of a change of plans. I think I told you guys how I'm doing a collab with uta
Um
We're actually doing a collab with some other vtubers instead
But I think you'll find that uh
There isn't much of a difference
You'll see tomorrow
You'll see you'll see I'll post the schedule tomorrow and you'll see what I mean. I don't think I have our schedules yet
Oh, maybe I do. Oh, I do have the schedules
Right here, I'll show you the schedule right now because you're here with me right now
So here's our schedule for next week um
So
So, um
Yeah, you made the schedule with me. It doesn't really matter. You made the schedule. We made it together. So it's fine. But um
Yeah, Monday we're playing chain together. Unfortunately, um
Uta and victoria couldn't join us. So instead we'll be joined by soprato and vivian voss instead
um
And she be of course she be was always joining us
Wednesday members a summer stream
Friday we'll be doing the apartment tour now. Don't get your don't get your hopes up
I'm just going to be taking pictures and showing you and I'm walking around my apartment with a camera
Um and sunday. I guess I'm playing piano for you. That's going to be rough
But yeah, this is our schedule take a screenshot. I don't know I'll post it tomorrow
um
Yeah, I'll post it tomorrow
But yeah, I think it'll be a fun week. We're gonna have fun
What piano music beginner piano music
Really shitty beginner songs
Okay, anyways, anyways, anyways, I'll see you
Monday
Have a good night or evening or I don't know anything hot cross buns. Literally. Yes
I will not take pictures of my underwear drawer. No, absolutely not
If you want to see more underwear picks you have to you have to beg on your knees on your hands and knees
And praise me a bunch if you want underwear picks, okay, okay, I'll see you tomorrow pookie. Love you. Bye. Bye
I said tomorrow fuck. I'm in monday monday. I'll see you monday
I